okay let's talk about student loans uh
white house says restarting student
loans is a high priority sparking
outrage okay tom this is a story you
have opinions on let me read it first
and then you can uh get right into it
it's a true uh truth uh uh uh is that
the one yes it is okay white house
secretary jen sackey recently announced
that the vitamin administration is not
planning on extending the student loan
payment pause
sparking outrage among debt advocates
and people who have struggled with
student loan repayments for years the
administration is planning to allow the
student debt payments paused to expire
at the end of january the pause which
was implemented to aid borrowers as the
economy was rocked by the pandemic has
been in place since march of 2020 2020
i'm angry at biden's backtracking on key
pillars he ran on cancellation i'm
fearing what the end of the moratorium
will do for so many people tweeted one
user other twitter user noted that
allowing repayments to start during a
critical election year is a poor
strategy for nation's top democrat which
she's right so thoughts tom what do you
think about this well there's like three
angles to this the first angle there is
is
i think it's political um and then the
other one is has a large banking and the
big numbers that you talk about right
now there's 1.7 trillion dollars of
student loans that is held by a
collective sum of about 43 million you
know
students that ran those up
so
you
the first thing you had is biden ran a
campaign promise when he was not yet the
nominee for president and he was
fighting against the bernie group that
was completely locked into bernie and
the elizabeth group elizabeth warren and
so he said if i'm elected i will cancel
half of the student loan for the lower
half of more you know uh you know
economically you know below some line
students half of them half of them okay
good well that would be
800 billion dollars and we just approved
a 2.5 trillion dollar debt increase so
where are you going to get the other
half you know 800 billion from it was it
would basically be tarp
for those that are carrying it you know
what the big three are naviant wells
fargo and discover hold 40 of the
student loan debt so if you're canceling
the debt what you have to do you have to
do something for the ben not the
servicers but you got to do something
for the banking industry and guess what
that would impact the size of bbb and
that would also impact the size of the
recent increase on the debt limit
because it's all related this 800
billion is going to come from summer
there it is one point seven three and
truly alone yeah and then you'll find in
there about 43 44 million americans that
are carrying that yep 43.2 yep yep so
you there's
a big number so the first problem is
you know i'm not unhappy to see a civil
war inside the democratic party about
this because this is when the that all
the all the independents moderates and
the republicans kind of sit this one out
and they're watching the democrats you
know it's starting to have a civil war
you know what's the problem with giving
things away to people for free you know
what's the problem with giving money or
things away to people for free they just
expect more
somebody else's money you eventually
have to stop
that's correct do you understand what
i'm saying so for example i had a friend
of mine best friend in the world we went
to first grade together high school
together military you meet everything no
cocaine
no cocaine this guy is not a cocaine guy
no so best friend
because it's other things but anyways so
but the friend at the other end of the
hall was the marijuana he was the
jacksons man i miss that guy so much if
i if he finds this i'd invite him to
tell these stories because he's that
funny okay tom stop okay so
so anyway so i'm uh uh uh
i'm i'm talking to this guy and he says
pat i'm going through tough times okay
never forget this i'm going through
tough times
i said uh what are you going through i
can't pay the office rent i said no
problem i got you this month on me
30 days later he makes money he buys a
nice 4 5 000 engagement ring for his
girl
rent comes he says i'm struggling as
well i said bro you just made i know how
much money you made yeah yeah he says no
no one more month so i said all right
one more month so at this point i'm
getting the good feeling of being a good
friend because he likes me do you know
what i'm saying it's like oh wow this is
so awesome what a great friendship we
have here right i'm bailing my friend
out two months three months it ends up
being eight months
eight months later he hasn't paid rent
then i have to tell him to do what
i the friend has to a victim
i have to tell him you cannot be in this
office anymore
after eight months of not paying rent
and evicting him guess who became the
enemy i'm the bad guy and he went
nuclear you know he went nuclear you
know my dad told me here's what my dad
told me he says parent you're about to
start making money this is 13 years ago
14 years ago i'm 27 years old so 16
years ago he says you're about to start
making money he says when you start
making real money everyone's going to
call you you have to have a basic rule
when people call you for money i said
what's that he said when people calling
they'll say i need to borrow five
thousand dollars he says never give them
lend them five thousand dollars because
the fastest way to lose a friend or
relative right he said instead say the
following you need five thousand dollars
you wanna borrow five thousand dollars i
can't give you five thousand dollars
however i can give you three hundred
dollars and you never have to pay it
back
so here's the no no but i need five
thousand i totally get it but the
difference is i don't wanna have hurt
our friendship right so instead of me
loaning you five thousand here's three
hundred bucks but never have to worry
about paying it back it's such a
confusing situation
because i still helped
and you can't walk away upset right and
i'm still like helping out so you kind
of it's kind of like this it's like
okay sure you know what i mean you just
kind of walk away i think dems have
given so much that eventually eventually
you have to stop giving them money and
they're going to turn against you
was it chas who said when he made a
little bit of money he called all of his
friends
made a bunch of money apparently you
know he was working on projects he
earned it he was a great actor and
getting good roles and getting good
paydays so he said to preempt what would
happen in hollywood where people ask
them hey 30 000 how about thirty
thousand i got a script i'm gonna finish
it am i getting development deal blah
blah blah blah blah blah
instead of that what he did he called
all his friends after he borrowed twenty
thousand dollars and then
they would assume oh my god that's
brilliant this is so good and then they
didn't call it a preemptive strike about
to get a million dollar check he calls
all his friends borrow him for 30 grand
they all say no
then he gets the million then when they
called they said bro you said no i can't
i can't do it so and a great actor can
pull that off but i think a chance
momentary i i just him dropping the
coffee cup in the usual suspects when he
sees the names on the board
yeah just
so good yeah okay cool let's continue
you're absolutely right and so to close
close close you know on student loans
you have a democrat civil war number one
number two
you can't throw another 100 billion on
the economy and number three
now you have a voting block that feels
that they
got screwed because they were promised
something and it's not there here's why
final caveat what about the people that
are going to school now i mean are they
going to be forgiven
going forward in perpetuity i mean what
if you're going to college in two years
and you have to take out loans you know
everybody else be before you had it
wiped away but you're going to be facing
i'm telling you this creates such a big
rift and a division it's not a pretty
sight because you you eventually have to
say no this is why you have to position
yourself and know if you start now
it's just a matter of time before they
hate you
starting january the 15th january the
15th is the first month the first day
that people aren't going to get the
child tax credit january the 31st is
when they find out that they're also not
getting an income tax refund so there's
going to be a lot of animosity before we
get to the first
month of the year right in the
democratic party among the the
constituencies that they're trying to
buy their votes
pat we could go deep on this an entire
podcast maybe we should sometime because
it's also the inflation that's happened
in the cost of tuition is because the
universities know they're only
accepting 10 of what comes in so there's
no problem with the demand
and they keep raising it because they
know that the federal government is
backing the student loans so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you